bonjour merci d'être avec nous pour un
nouveau numéro de dimanche en politique
avec aujourd'hui une question y at il
trop d'éoliennes en bourgogne
c'est ce que des associations ont
dénoncé la semaine dernière à dijon
alors que la bourgogne n'est pourtant
pas une des premières régions françaises
sur ce sujet pour en débattre sur ce
plateau avec nous mourad la wes bonjour
bonjour vous êtes un des porte parole
d'europe écologie les verts pour la
bourgogne
michel de broissia bonjour bonjour vous
êtes le président de la cbf c qui
regroupe des associations de bourgogne
et de franche comté
c'est vous qui organisez le
rassemblement de la semaine dernière
vous êtes par ailleurs maire de
champagne sur vingeanne 7 en côte d'or
tout à fait emmanuel choosing bonjour
bonjour vous êtes le délégué général de
ce qu'on appelle le cluster éolien qui
regroupe l'ensemble des entreprises du
secteur éolien dans la région bourgogne
et vous êtes très nombreux chez vous à
avoir réagi sur le sujet à nous avoir
envoyé des messages des messages qui
seront cités et lui lorsqu il en sera
question pendant cette émission
notre question d'un production était
certes lapidaire il ya trop d'éoliennes
mais elle pose d'entrée le sujet michel
de broissia
d'après vous il y aurait trop
d'éoliennes en bourgogne
alors que sur les 22 ancienne région
nous ne sommes que la 12e en nombre
d'éoliennes
oui mais avant de dire ça il faut se
poser la question à quoi sert veut-elle
et qu'est ce qu'elle donne donc il faut
faire un retour d'expérience est
nécessairement il faut passer par le
parc de saint seine l'abbaye
donc si vous voulez moi je suis tombé
dans ces éoliennes par hasard en 2010
parce que j'arrivais chez moi et en tant
qu'ingénieur en tant que même docteur en
environnement si vous voulez je me suis
posé la question j'ai acheté les données
météo et j'ai commencé à faire des
simulations pour voir ce que ça donnait
et quand j'ai je ne comprenais pas parce
que je vais aller au comité de pilotage
du mirebellois où on voulait faire un
parc éolien et je disais ça ne marche
pas et donc personne ne me croyait
jusqu'au jour où quelqu'un m'a fourni
les comptes sociaux de la société en
question du promoteur pour l'allée de la
résout vrai beaucoup de sujets vous
beaucoup de sujets oui oui mais c'est
fondamental parce que finalement on
s'apercevait au bout de cinq ans de
fonctionnement que la société perd des
15 millions d'euros donc à partir de là
si vous voulez le problème se poser de
façon complètement différente
donc on va on va faire répondre parce
qu'on va avancer on peut se poser la
question pourquoi les éoliennes sont si
grandes maintenant alors vous ouvrez
c'est bien ce que je disais vous ouvrez
plusieurs sujets à la fois d'abord cette
première question morale de la whey
c'est ce qu'on peut la pause est comme
ça d'ailleurs y at-il trop d'éoliennes
ou pas nous n'aurions pas trop
d'éoliennes
d'ailleurs le seul droit sien dit que
les ingénieurs en environnement dr à
l'environnement il est aussi qu'il est
il est pour la préservation de
l'environnement
nous en parlerons parce que là dessus
les écologistes ont tout de même sont
les mieux placés sur cette question
maintenant pour revenir à la réalité de
l'éolien les éoliennes sont en majorité
très bien accepté je veux pour preuve de
deux indicateurs le premier indicateur
c'est les réponses positives aux
sollicitations d'investissement des
citoyens de plus en plus le deuxième
point c'est les nombreuses visites
actuellement est de plus en plus
organisés ou pas dans les parcs éoliens
pro pas à ces jeux permettent juste de
répondre en tant que riverain du du parc
de 500 ch peu rassuré monsieur de
broissia les éoliennes tournent toujours
à saint seine effectivement comme pour
toute société sils société perd autant
d'argent sur une année évidemment un
parc éolien ne va pas continuer donc la
société en question développent de
nouveaux projets donc soit les vraiment
suicidaire soit effectivement
effectivement il ya aucune utilité mais
on n'est pas du tout dans ce schéma
aujourd'hui alors on va essayer de poser
la question peut-être une autre manière
à chaque fois on peut d'ailleurs là pour
la pause et de plein de manières
différentes
est-ce que ce qui est en cause dans
ces manifestations dans ou dans la
défense de l'éolien c'est le fait que
l'éolien soit gênant ou est-ce qu'il ya
aussi la question de l'utilité réelle de
l'éolien est ce qu'aujourd'hui l'éolien
sert à quelque chose si on veut
préserver l'environnement ou est ce que
parce que c'est ce que vous dites il
génère pas plus de problèmes qu'ils
n'emmènent d'intérêt on commence par hu
man au-dessus d'eux alors si on prend
les chiffres des experts de l'agencé
internationale de l'énergie on h sur un
schéma qui vise à peu près à 20 à 25 %
d'électricité d'origine éolienne à
travers le monde donc c'est une énergie
qui en très forte croissance
pourquoi parce qu'elle est mature de
plus en plus compétitive créatrice de
richesses locales ce qui permet d'éviter
l'indépendance par rapport aux énergies
fossiles donc effectivement c'est une
tendance qui est lourde avec des
technologies qui évoluent énormément
très clairement on aurait posé la
question il ya 15 ou 20 ans est ce que
la région est propice à l'énergie
éolienne
vu le degré technologies actuelles la
réponse est évidemment oui d'accord on a
plein on a plein de messages de gens qui
nous disent mais pourquoi le faire dans
la région la région pourquoi n'y a aucun
intérêt pour l'éolien le vent est trop
faible on est obligé de mettre des mâts
très très haut on a là on en a on en a
beaucoup comme ça beaucoup beaucoup de
questions comme ça alors c'est un
phénomène physique et naturel plus on
vend auteurs mathématiquement plus on a
de gisement de vent donc c'est vrai que
à titre personnel moi j'ai développé un
logiciel et je peux rassurer monsieur de
broissia tous les sites ne sont pas
propices à l'énergie éolienne en
bourgogne
mais effectivement on a des sites qui
sont plus propices alors si avec un
petit peu de provocation la france a
signé il ya moins d'un an
la cap 21 est ce que on peut à la fois
dire il faut lutter contre le
réchauffement et s'opposer comme le font
toutes vos associations a finalement
tous les parcs éoliens qui se montrent
alors vous abordez vous aussi beaucoup
de sujets à la fois oui oui je pose est
donc vous avez posé le plus de problèmes
de l'éolien par rapport au réchauffement
que vous avez posé la question de
l'intermittence et de l'utilité des
éoliennes
oui et donc effectivement si vous voulez
on prend le mois de septembre 2016
rapport rte
résultat les éoliennes ont marché en
gros
12 5% du temps donc ça veut dire que
pendant 85 % du temps il n'y avait rien
et donc il fallait remplacer par autre
chose et pardonne moi il ya des
centrales nucléaires il ya justement
alors là c'est là où c'est génial
effectivement tout d'un coup madame
royal hier s'inquiète envoie une lettre
au pdg d'edf en lui disant agissez
d'urgence rendez vous compte qui a
presque onze mille mégawatts d'éoliennes
installées en france aujourd'hui donc
largement beaucoup plus que toutes les
tranches nucléaires qui sont arrêtés
aujourd'hui
donc moi je mets au défi aujourd'hui les
partisans des éoliennes de prendre le
relais parce que c'est ça le sujet il y
laisse croire qu'ils vont prendre le
relais mais savent pas le faire en fait
et donc qu'est-ce qu'on fait vous savez
ce qu'on fait on ressuscite quatre
centrales à charbon en france
voilà ce qui a été décidé dans la
semaine qui vient de se passer je me
vois je vous vois chez lafuma d'accord
avait alors prouvez le premièrement
l'énergie
les énergies renouvelables vont devenir
de plus en plus elles le sont déjà
ils sont indispensables elvis est
atteint les six mois terminés je vais
terminer vous venez c'est terminé
premièrement en france on n'a pas de
pétrole on a peint d'uranium
on a par contre quand on a du vent on a
du soleil on a de l'eau alors la france
un potentiel éolien
c'est le deuxième européen après le
royaume-uni et vous le savez alors
ensuite à partir de ça on a commencé
avec ce potentiel éolien et la
technologie actuelle des éoliennes parce
qu'elles sont très performantes
contrairement à celle d'il ya 20 ans
elles peuvent fonctionner avec ce que
nous avons en bourgogne s'est terminée
vous parlait d'ailleurs des éoliennes
qui s'arrête
1 parce que vous oubliez une chose c'est
que l'éolienne quand elle s'arrête soi
et en maintenance ou aux fonctions de la
trajectoire des wampas que les vents
évidemment ils ne sont pas tout le temps
dans une direction mais ça rien à voir
avec ce que vous dites
à savoir si sa réponse des lois
mathématiques physique des ingénieurs
des deux côtés sur ce sujet moi j'ai
envie de faire répondre à ce que vous
aviez dit pour qu'on avance
point par point et managing sur un point
est ce que c'est vrai que quand les
éoliennes s'arrête parce qu a pas de
vent ben il faut utiliser des centrales
à charbon pour compenser et générer
finalement aller à l'encontre des
objectifs dako 21 on va dire c'est
absolument faux les centrales à charbon
dont monsieur de broissia parle existe
déjà les centrales à charbon existent
déjà depuis un siècle en france on en a
fermé quelques unes depuis les
implantations d'éoliennes preuve en est
celle de montceau à lui si la tendance
est lourde c'est à dire qu'on ferme
aujourd'hui des centrales d'origine
russie monsieur c'est clair on vient de
suspendre la recette c'est la nature y
autour de quatre centrales on vient de
suspendre la fermeture tout à fait je
suis d'accord avec vous voilà on suspend
la fermeture mais là la cause n'est pas
l'éolien la cause et l'arrêt de tranche
nucléaire
mais alors pourquoi l'éolien prend pas
le relais c'est tout c'est tout bête
c'est tout bête tout ça c'est tout
simplement
nathan permettez permettez moi d'y
répondre tout simplement parce que nous
n'avons pas assez développer les
énergies renouvelables en france
alors c'est d'ouvrir des comptes jusqu'à
quand il faut les développer il faudrait
mettre 60 mille cent vingt mille avec
avec des résultats comme 12 5% de
rendement sur un mois mais comment
fait-on on est on est pas du tout dans
les rendements que vous décrivez donner
l'exemple de l'allemagne l'allemagne à
développer des énergies renouvelables
sont équivalentes à leur énergie
pilotable ils n'ont pas retiré 1 et
kaoua d'énergie pilotable c'est à dire
tes anciennes attendait s'il vous plaît
si vous permettez moi juste d'y répondre
l'allemagne a quand même retirer 25 % de
son parc électrique au travers des
centrales nucléaires c'est énorme mais
ils les ont remplacés pièce que à
charbon le jure
citez moi un sens large de l'or la jeune
fille témoin six témoins seuls nos deux
centrales est finalement non seulement
pas soin de ses marchés je vais vers les
magnifiques sont fausses monsieur d
attendez je vivais en allemagne je peux
vous l'assurer l'énergie au charbon
l'électricité au charbon
elle a toujours été présente en
allemagne et de manière beaucoup plus
importante qu'aujourd'hui et vous ne
dites pas qu aujourd'hui l'allemagne
crée de nouvelles centrales au charbon
et qu'elle en ouvre encore aujourd'hui
c'est faux c'est vrai cela c'est faux ce
sont des six femmes ce sont des efforts
oui tout à fait alors là je vous le dis
ce plan le prouver comptez six témoins
ont centrale a seulement adressé dans
une avance moi je reviens parce que je
reviendrai à la fois les énergies
fossiles dont parle messieurs mais
également un peu de nucléaire parce que
de ce côté là
notre indépendance énergétique elle est
dans les énergies renouvelables
nous avons ce défi à relever nous avons
les engagements de la france donc je
crois que monsieur a parlé à l'instant à
savoir les réductions des gaz à effet de
serre et toutes ces choses là donc nous
avons des engagements à l'union
européenne des engagements avec la coop
21 nous avons la loi de la transition
énergétique les énergies renouvelables
sont obligatoires on n'a pas le choix il
ya deux autres réseaux l'environnement
et la santé publique d'une part
l'économie la stratégie de
réindustrialisation de notre région
d'autre part sur le plan environnemental
nous devons diviser par quatre le les
gaz à effet de serre d'ici 2050 et vous
le savez très bien le réchauffement
climatique à moins que les yeux ya moi
que vous soyez là moins qu'à vous soyez
à un climato sceptiques
le fait d'être ici en belgique nous
retirer quand la réduction de la
concentration avant la réception de 50%
à l'horizon 2050 des gaz à effet de
serre obligatoire la part des énergies
renouvelables doivent passer à 23 % en
2020 à 32% 2005 en belgique et politique
là on attendait tant de la technique
attendez je me dis un truc vous devez
oublier
écoutez le
je suis content je fais des études
scientifiques mais là je suis un
politique je vois les choses de manière
beaucoup plus large que vous je suis
désolé de vous le dire de cette manière
parce que faire de la politique c'est
avoir des projets de société c'est
réfléchir au projet de société est l'un
de nos projets à nous c'est de race
c'est de maintenir le réchauffement
climatique à moins de 2 degrés et de
préférence à moins que sinon non mais
qu'est ce que vous allez vous êtes maire
de votre commune
mais vous vous prétendez protéger
l'environnement
mais comment qu'est-ce que vous avez
léguer à nos enfants de vos concitoyens
sur répondre à une question comment
faites-vous quand le vent ne souffle pas
pendant des mois par quoi le remplacer
vous ouais j'ai soudain fondamentale
meilleure manche je veux dire est ce que
le vent ne peut pas soufflé pendant un
mois
nous maintenons mais c'est simple il a
souvent soit celle des dames en 2016 je
n'ai pas est-ce que c'est le sujet m'a
redonné mois mais ce que c'est
ensuite j'espère mais je termine sur ce
point parce qu'il ne s'agit pas
uniquement de faire un pari d'éoliennes
100% et on dira nous rase tout le reste
là il s'agit de faire de relever le défi
des énergies renouvelables les toutes
énergies renouvelables confondues vous
avez l'éolien c'est nécessaire vous avez
le photovoltaïque c'est nécessaire la
biomasse est nécessaire donc tout ça
ensemble ça nous permet de faire un
réseau intelligent de petites centrales
et pas besoin de faire d'énormes ma
chance c'est ce qu'on appelle le mix
énergétique
pas tout à fait avec les jeux/jouets
nucléaire juste un mot pardon justement
démarche unique pour refermer cas qu'on
avance
je voyais vous agitez c'est vrai qu on a
un scénario de l'ademe qui envisageait à
un scénario 100% énergies renouvelables
il n'a jamais été question de faire 100%
d'éolien les énergies complémentaires
les énergies renouvelables pardon sont
complémentaires
l'hydroélectricité par exemple est un
excellent moyen de stockage de
l'électricité éolienne c'est ce que fait
le danemark avec la norvège par exemple
ce qui lui permet d'atteindre 40 %
d'éolien en basculant effectivement le
surplus en période de surplus vers la
norvège et inversement quand nous
n'avons pas de vent on importe
l'électricité doit électrique
je voudrais souligner un point la région
ce mais aussi très fortement en avant
sur des technologies de stockage de
demain pour permettre justement de
pallier ces difficultés artistes n'ont
pas c'est pas gratis base et parce que
t'as pas gratis penser au stockage
permettez moi juste de terminer
permettez moi juste de terminer la
région veut être en pointe sur sur le
stockage via l'hydrogène
c'est un pari certes ambitieux mais qui
s'inscrit dans cette dans cette lignée
c'est vrai que c'est un enjeu majeur
mais qui concerne l'éolien mais toutes
les sources d'électricité aujourd'hui on
ne sait pas stocker non plus le
nucléaire ni d'autres sources
d'électricité donc l'avenir il est
évidemment dans les problématiques de
stockage et la région l'a compris et on
travaille avec en parler de technique
moi j'ai envie de me faire avancer mais
justement c'est là dessus que vous allez
pouvoir répondre parce qu'on va il faut
pas qu'on passe une demi heure sur la
technique
je pense qu'il ya déjà des gens qui sont
partis aux marchés à cause de ça en
revanche nombre de la hauteur des
éoliennes si vous voulez bien alors que
en l'étendant en l'étendant si vous
voulez bien michel de broissia à votre
jardin en plaisantant ou à votre arrière
cour vous savez ce que lewis que les
américains appellent nimby voilà bat pas
dans mon arrière-cour c'est à dire je
veux bien tout mais je le veux pas chez
moi
est ce que c'est ça qui se joue autour
des éoliennes c'est à dire globalement
tout le monde est d'accord pour réduire
les gaz à effet de serre mais les
éoliennes on les veut bien dans un
endroit qui serait au large de la côte
par exemple mais pas chez soi
et est-ce que ça ça a vraiment un impact
sur les paysages est ce qu'on doit
considérer que les paysages sont abîmés
détruits par les héritages
est ce que c'est ça que disent vos
adhérents je crois qu'il ya un très
grand des prix de la ruralité
parce que je vous avais envoyé
malheureusement vous rêvez pas le passé
mais je vous ai envoyé une photo un
photomontage fait par un promoteur donc
de d'un petit village on préfère ne pas
passer les photos noms qui se trouve
qu'ils se trouvent mary baissé en mai
pascale forcément drive moteur m'a fait
par mois si vous voulez et qui montre
une éolienne à 1000 mètres d'un village
c'est hallucinant c'est insupportable il
donc pardon à concourès insupportable
qu'on soit d'accord sur les mobiles
qu'on soit d'accord mais il aurait fallu
que vous acceptiez de montrer ma mon
photomontage c'est tout simplement
impossible à vivre
quelle est la distance légale en france
par dont il a distancé la les 2 500 m et
les ridicules et donc et donc nous notre
association de ce cocktail est très
claire elle demande dit fouad comme
distance dix fois la hauteur des
diène voilà du bon sens au minimum c'est
quelque chose que l'on demande un
minimum c'est ce qui est par exemple en
bavière
la bavière le land allemand il a il a
pris cette cette règle est effectivement
moi je suis déjà allé à munich sans voir
une éolienne
donc soyons pas hypocrites à vue parce
qu'elle n'a pas ou parce que lorsqu'on
passe lorsque effectivement les règles
font puis en a peu voilà voilà donc ça
réduit fin mai 2009 choses en pologne
enfin ça réduit ça rend humain
l'implantation dans l'alluré d'un
territoire l'allemagne est le premier
pays européen en termes de oui mais
finalement la bavière qui est une région
qui nous ressemblent par son patrimoine
et ses paysages elle a su les préserver
nous pas alors vous voulez répondre à de
l'ouest là dessus sur wii je voudrais
reprendre sur sur l'aspect affreux des
éoliennes
1 loi aussi monsieur leroi siège est ici
deux photos se sont pas des
photomontages c'est les photos de la
réalité l'une avec des éoliennes sur
l'horizon une autre et l'autre avec des
gros pylônes et défilent aux tensions
qui traversent un village et je peux
vous dire non mais je vais pas les
montrer puisque c'est pas la règle ici
on fait match nul mais je peux vous
garantir que vous présentez ça au coût
d'un moyen
là aucune hésitation pour choisir de
voir cela cela dit j'ai rigolé dit tout
choix énergétiques
tout choix de développement que nous
faisons impacte notre paysage impacte
notre mode de vie
alors vous acceptez bien et des zones
commerciales les zones industrielles qui
sont comme pas des des modèles
d'architecturé vous acceptez bien les
centrales nucléaires les autres à
thermique qui qui ne sont pas plus vous
acceptez bien les lignes tgv vous
acceptez les lignes les infrastructures
autoroutières autoroutières et les
aéroports qui est détruisant plus
d'environnements vous acceptez tout ça
mais vous refusez les rôles yens alors
que les éoliennes sont harmonieusement
intégré dans le paysage est ce que vous
acceptez sociaux tu veux nous voilà dans
quel monde vous vivez là attention
attendait justement j'y viens parce que
je vous dire le paysage et année le
monde et le mec tout ce que je vous dis
c'est tout simplement nous devons vivre
avec les besoins de la population des
besoins fondamentaux doit être à
l'écouté de ses besoins et ses besoins
c'est respirer un air censé être en
bonne santé
s'alimenter correctement se déplaçait se
chauffer proprement et là-dessus il n'y
a pas de solution on est mobilisé en
posant des problèmes de santé sur des
jeux il ya deux mois de l'ouest en
particulier
j'y reviendrai je termine juste sur ce
match mais je persiste sur ce coin cela
dit pour vous rassurer il ne s'agit pas
de faire n'importe quoi
il existe qu'on appelle un code de
l'environnement toute installation
d'éoliennes toutes installations
d'énergie et de production d'énergie
renouvelable est soumise à une étude
d'impact sur l'environnement sur le
bruit et les soumise à un plus en plus
il ya un autre garde fous qui vient de
sortir la loi de biodiversité vient de
mettre un outil législatif au point de
créer un nouvel et au législatif qui
s'appelle l'atlas paysager le but de cet
atlas paysage et cette fois ci en faveur
de la préservation des paysages tout ça
vous êtes vous monsieur parce que je
suis dedans je dois n'avait pas l'air de
connaître qui vous quand vous coupez
2004 sont impératives est ce que vous
comprenez tout de même je vous donnerai
la parole ensuite je dis est ce que vous
comprenez ce que disent les gens qui
vivent à la campagne quand il d'un seul
coup alors qu'ils ont eu un paysage
devant eux depuis peut-être pour
certains plusieurs générations il ya des
éoliennes et que leur quotidien visuel
est complètement changé on peut
comprendre quand même je crois que cette
force les gens feront très bien ce que
moi je tiens à rassurer ces messieurs
dames
je comprends très bien compte
effectivement l'habitude est perturbé
par quelque chose de nouveau
on peut effectivement se poser des
questions on peut être inquiet donc je
demande tout simplement à ces personnes
de se renseigner un peu plus ou surtout
de ne pas se laisser avoir par des
mauvais discours ou des discours
finalement complotistes de se renseigner
sur le bilan positif des éoliennes aussi
bien notamment sur le le bilan
touristique
le bilan un paysage est là mais je vous
garantis à les voir en champagne ardenne
allez voir dans l'économie gbagbo reçoit
des visites de parcs éoliens
mais il faut se renseigner un peu plus
bon ensuite les nuisances elles sont
nettement plus faibles que les nuisances
habituel quotidienne par exemple sur le
bruit le bruit d'une éolienne à 300 m
c'est le bruit d'une conversation calme
et le cam archer 12 5% du temps mais
ensuite en avant et ensuite on avancera
un mot effectivement sur les paysages
je voyais hocher la tête quand je disais
vous comprenez que les gens et je n'ai
pas envie d'avoir ça se borner quoi
alors il faut savoir de quoi on parle on
a aujourd'hui à peu près dans la grande
région 4000 commune l'objectif c'est
d'avoir à peu près 900 éoliennes sur la
grande région
ça relativise un petit peu les choses en
disant ça fait finalement une éolienne
pour quatre à cinq communes donc on est
quand même sur une dimension qui reste
limité tous les sites ne sont pas
propices moi je comprend parfois
effectivement les inquiétudes qui sont
émises par par la population et je dois
avouer qu'un projet éolien ça doit se
construire
alors on a sans doute des choses à
améliorer en termes de concertation en
termes de présentation en termes d'
échanges avec les élus on peut prendre
un projet un petit peu symbolique non
loin d'ici h à mol dans le jura où la
population a été associés dès le départ
et aujourd'hui on a plusieurs centaines
d'habitants qui investissent dans ce
qu'on appelle une éolienne citoyenne
donc effectivement une éolienne sur sur
huit ou neuf je relance juste je
prolonge ce que vous dites quand vous
parlez de populations parce qu'on a eu
beaucoup de questions de messages de
gens qui nous parlent de consultation et
de populations bébé 21 qui nous dit par
exemple pourquoi la population locale
d'un projet n'ait pas consulté
c'est l'élu local avec son conseil qui
décide pour tout le monde
où est la démocratie et c'est un des
points qu'on entend souvent sur ce sujet
des trois épis vous ne répondrez mais je
voudrais avant je voudrais aborder le
problème de la santé et du code de santé
publique parce que ça c'est quand même
quelque chose d'important
figurez vous que le code de santé
publique dit qu'il ya tapage nocturne à
partir du moment où le bruit dépasse 30
décibels la nuit
eh bien qu'est ce qui s'est passé comme
s'en empêcher de mettre des éoliennes
qu'est ce qu'on a fait on a changé on a
mis en affaires on a pris un arrêté qui
permet d'augmenter le bruit la nuit
jusqu'à 35 décibels c'est à dire que les
riverains d'éoliennes en plus de voir
clignoter d'éoliennes à deux niveaux on
a d'ailleurs des questions sur les
lumières aussi ses gènes à sa planque
ils vont se payer le bruit la nuit alors
me dites pas que c'est rien moi je suis
en relation avec un habitant de montceau
écharnant qui habite qui a une maison
qui s'est construite à flanc de coteau
il est à 680 mètres d'une éolienne
dès que le vent souffle du sud il peut
pas dormir c'est la vérité et donc quand
le code de santé publique j'ai passée
l'aîné seuil de 30 à 35 db ça veut dire
que ça autorise un brin vous contestez
le code de santé je ne conteste pas au
contraire justement je voudrais qu'ils
s'appliquent aux riverains d'éoliennes
et ça c'est honteux c'est à dire que on
a bidouillé le code de santé publique
pour que les riverains d'éoliennes en
prennent plein la gueule
c'est le mépris de la ruralité total et
quand on fait passer à 35 décibels ça
revient à multiplier par trois le bruit
à la source c'est considérable alors
c'est honteux
et quand je lis dans vos publications
monsieur monsieur là où est ce que vous
êtes contre le gigantisme des éoliennes
il est impossible de faire autrement
parce qu'il ya pas de vent dans notre
région la seule solution c'est
d'augmenter la surface de la voilure
parce que j'y peux rien l'énergie
cinétique du vent elle dit ça avec vous
la technique vous avez pourtant
interdite oui mais voilà
vous voulez je peux juste répondre aux
quelques données au niveau du cou
effectivement ce qu'il faut prendre en
considération c'est qu'aujourd'hui les
distances certes sont de 500 mètres pour
une éolienne mais on est à 150 mètres
d'une autoroute à 150 mètres pour une
ligne tgv et on n'a même pas de distance
pour les lignes à très haute tension
bref c'est pas parce que c'est à dire
bien pour les autres qui font je suis
d'accord avec vous les technologies
évoluent un bruit qui revient comique
d'un vélo avec le bruit de la part qui
passe devant le vase et support est à
vous prétendez qu'elle ne tourne que 12%
et vous me dites les gens ne peuvent
plus dormir la nuit le vent souffle et
d'un large secteur sud
j'ai dit quand le vin souffre d'un large
secteur où il nous reste deux minutes
sur la consultation pas tout de même est
ce que il faudrait modifier la façon
voilà c'est le prix fort loges qui
tourne c'est ça michel droit cela
fait-il encore rien dit sur cette
question je reprendrai juste très vite
sur le caractère voulien le caractère
des grandes éoliennes il ya aussi le
petit éolien pour vous rassurer
bon je peux sur la consultation est un
mot sur la consultation passant sur une
chronique est participatif chez europe
ecologie c'est absolument une somme
d'ailleurs c'est au coeur de la
gouvernance écologistes la consultation
pour relever les projets doivent
toujours être co construit du début
jusqu'à la fin
ce qui n'est pas le cas on est d'accord
pour l'instant dans la plupart des cas
c'est pas toujours le cas effectivement
pour aboutir à des projets au sol et ben
je vous cite center parcs dans la
déposition enquête publique qui viennent
chez nous ils donnent un avis
défavorable non et le préfet sinde vous
n'avez pas que nous n'avons pas la même
façon à natoye j'y peux rien c'est
n'avons pas la même vision rites
nous n'avons pas la même vision de la
consultation citoyenne vous et moi c'est
le cas chez moi je laissais terminé s'il
vous plaît ne vont pas la même vision
des consultations citoyennes comme voici
maintenant il faut savoir une chose
c'est que le dialogue jeudi de ne
dialogue pas
la mise devant le fait accompli le
dialogue avec la population était une
nécessité démocratique
sur ce point je vous dire une chose
aujourd'hui les citoyens ils veulent
participer et tracteurs des
développements et que l'aménagement de
leur territoire il ya plein de citoyens
qui ne sont pas d'accord dans ces
associations c'est amour sociétale et
les gens ne supportent plus d'être mis
devant le fait accompli
en revanche côté un projet éco construit
entre citoyens collectivités locales
comme ça se passe par exemple dans le
clunisois pour des projets dans tous les
oies ou à charolles je ne laisserai pas
des éoliennes je l'avais sur la commune
à côté je suis la même chose je ne
rigole pas qui c'est un sujet très
sérieuse je suis très au sérieux ce que
disent nos concitoyens mais je peux vous
garantir que les dessus je suis
intraitable sur la course vous savez
quoi
j'avais regrettable parce que je vous
arrête tout de suite regardé 30 secondes
jusqu'au petit jusqu'à maintenant non
mésanges 25 ont cessé je vous coupe les
lycées est terminée nous reste 20
secondes je dois juste annoncé que c'est
ségolène royal qui sera justement
parlera sûrement d'éolien dans la
deuxième partie la prénationale cette
émission non on n'a pas su aller donc là
j'en suis désolé mais avec félix c'était
un vrai débat merci à tous les trois
arbres dimanche au revoir
mercredi vivez l'événement